Kristen is with us Kristen is in
Wisconsin hi Kristen welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show how can Doctor John and I
help hi thank you for having me on your
show if it's an honor to talk to you you
too what's up I have a question it's um
it's a friendship question
I'll play the just a little bit and then
if you need more questions or more
details I'll let you know this is what
friendship is forgiveness I had a real
good friend that I was friends with for
a while and we had a falling-out about a
year ago oh and she still I still I'm
not she we still have not gotten
forgiveness hard to get forgiveness from
her oh well he let me borrow her bike we
were both in our 40s and her daughter
has a teenager it has a bike and I took
it to a horse show in Kentucky and it
was stolen so I get home and the week I
got home my mom actually went into the
hospital for three and hematoma and so I
did not respond right away to this I
didn't pay for the bike and I didn't
replace it right away and I was just
really stressed out and anyway she had
wanted me to meet her at the bike store
to buy her daughter a new bike and I
just told her that's not good
you know that's really not reasonable or
is it was an old bike anyways and just
plenty of money in anyways it I did wind
up paying or $500 for the bike 500 it
was a bicycle or a motorcycle and bikes
are expensive I mean well this is a nice
bike I know they're expensive but this
is not like okay this daughter had it
what ages is daughter 14 nicest girl in
the world but mom definitely holds a
grudge so what's the what's your
question
so I see this I see them every day
because we poured our horses at the same
barn and you know it's been a mental
struggle for me just going out there and
being ignored and you know not even I'll
say hello and there's it's just I've not
even treated like I'm a human being
anymore but I'm not asking for her to be
my friend I just I'm sorry I written her
notes um it's a view huh yeah this is
messy have you just taken her aside and
said I'm sorry right I guess I haven't
really gotten that closer every time she
sees me walking to her she walks away so
it's it sounds like you have a choice to
make right so you had a traumatic moment
in history
you lost somebody's bike I think it is
fair to replace their bike and now again
yeah well it's a $500 bike or tuner or
bike doesn't matter how much money they
have if they're millionaires or
kajillion heirs you lost the bike and
you pay for it I've come to some terms
with that and of course we want people
to be sympathetic to us especially when
our times of you know tragedy in our own
homes but it sounds like you've got a
decision to make you want to carry this
around with you or you want to take the
first step and say hey I'm sorry and I
should have taken care of the bike
differently my mom's in a bad situation
I didn't handle it right and I'm sorry
and you can move on yeah there may be a
difference on who's at fault who's right
in my personal life I've decided I
decided several years ago I don't care
anymore I'm not going to carry other
people's baggage around even if they're
they should have been more sensitive to
me even if they should have handled
something differently I'm not gonna
carry that because it weighs me down
hurts my knees or hurts my shoulders
hurts my neck I'm not gonna do that and
so I'm going to go first I'm gonna reach
out and say I played a part in this
separation and I'm sorry and I wish
they'd handle the better and I didn't
and I hope you forgive me yeah so that
would change the language of the way you
describe this story forever
if you do that in other words the
language would never have anything to do
about nice young lady but her mother
carries a grudge it would never have
anything to do with she's got plenty of
money she could buy a bike never have
anything to do with well she should have
understood my mother had him tell me we
would never first say phrases like those
again you would just say yeah I was
wrong hey I didn't pony up the money as
quickly as I should have I didn't react
well to this and if she can't accept
that then you've at least set it all
down but when you qualify all of your
all of your apologies with qualifiers it
takes the sincerity off the apology
well you never get to you never get to
put the bricks down and if this other
mom called me I'd be telling her the
same thing yeah right I'd be telling her
the same thing yeah just say you're
sorry put it down there just forget it
move on it's not nothing is worth that
but and then if she still won't talk to
you that's her baggage to carry you not
yours I believe me there's some people
won't talk to Dave Ramsey I can promise
you and I block like 15,000 on Twitter
does that count